thank you
what's the deal with airplane peanut
peanuts the Tim Dillon show is one of
the most popular comedy podcasts in the
world raking in over 100 million views
and half a million subscribers since
joining YouTube in 2016 but with growing
concerns amongst comedians regarding
YouTube's strict monetization policies
and blatant corporate censorship it
looks like Tim Dillon's days on this
platform might be coming to an end I
don't know what's going on anymore and
it doesn't matter xqc leaves twitch
agrees to two-year 100 million dollar
contract with Kik so that's what I'm
saying there there are other places you
know we might start uploading the show
to Twitter we're thinking about it in
addition to YouTube we don't know we
might start uploading the show to rumble
we don't know right now but we were
experimenting with all kinds of things
but we don't know the direction that
things are going to go in the media
space but things do seem to be heading
to an interesting place where there are
more eyeballs now across many different
platforms and that might be the best way
to do it obviously fans of Tim Dillon's
know that online censorship has always
been a battle but this issue seemed to
have reached a Breaking Point last week
after episode 349 of the Tim Dillon show
was struck with an age restriction Tim
went to Twitter saying quote after
YouTube has made people sign in to watch
the show for a third time I've decided
to start uploading complete podcasts to
Twitter and Rumble as well I don't think
YouTube is the future for comedy the
sensors have gone completely insane and
it's not just Tim who's speaking out for
change the same day Tim sent out his
initial tweet Giannis popis chimed in
with his two cents saying the future of
comedy and comedy podcast is on Twitter
at Elon Musk let's make it happen
YouTube censors too much theovan was
also quick to use Twitter as a resource
after his episode with Roseanne Barr was
completely removed from YouTube for some
[__] reasons that we'll have to
cover more in an upcoming video Theo
tweeted his full episode saying my
podcast with Roseanne was removed from
another platform so I wanted it to be
able to live somewhere amen many people
were hoping the threat of leaving
YouTube would be enough to curb this
censorship in some way but just
yesterday Tim informed his fans because
of YouTube's strike we can't upload a
YouTube episode this week episode will
be out on all audio platforms besides
YouTube being the premier video sharing
platform for people on Earth the other
reason this censorship is so dangerous
is because these are just jokes
especially in Tim Dillon's case where
his unique ranting style perfectly
highlights the day-to-day stupidity of
our culture and pushes back on some of
these insane ideas I used to get coked
out of my face put a bunch of friends in
my Suburban
drive around really wealthy areas in
Long Island and point to the houses and
go they deserve this money
they deserve it
screaming sweating screaming and my
friends are like yeah yeah
back of the car they were terrified
they're like are we gonna die what's
wrong with this guy I mean if they
deserve it
don't take their money make your own
money making every single viewer sign in
giving Channel strikes that ultimately
lead to YouTube bands or the scariest
idea of all that slowly over time these
guys will start self-censoring to stay
in YouTube's good graces without even
noticing these are all extremely
negative factors when it comes to
producing good comedy and if the past
few years have taught us anything it's
that good things happen when comedians
go independent as we've seen with the
migration to Austin and the mothership
the amount of shows finding massive
success on patreon and all the
self-produced podcasts and specials that
have been receiving millions and
millions of views the problem is YouTube
used to be the number one tool helping
comedians break away from that industry
but now it's trying to apply the same
shackles as far as Rumble goes their
entire platform is still very early on
in development Tim's friend Steve will
do it is one of the top creators over
there after getting completely banned
from YouTube a few months ago
comedian-wise they have Jim Brewer
Russell Brand has a huge page Sam
tripoli's podcast is over there
everything is still very experimental
over on Rumble which is why I think
Twitter is most likely the place that
many people will watch the Tim Dylan
show moving forward especially with Elon
in control providing an extra sense of
security when it comes to free speech
for the foreseeable future and maybe
YouTube will sense this growing threat
to their business and release some of
these restrictions it seems like
everyone in comedy is getting sick of
YouTube's [__] to some extent hopefully
something changes soon because this is
still the premiere video platform the
easiest to use and most importantly has
the most users and the widest reach and
it's just a great place for watching
videos the ability to share videos the
end screens and the suggested content is
always on point it's just a shame
they've begun to create an echo chamber
of allowed ideas I do think Twitter is
more realistic than Rumble but even when
you consider the massive amount of users
on Twitter it's still just hard to
imagine anyone sitting down and watching
an hour-long podcast over there although
that's probably just because up to this
point it's never been done and I think
most comedy fans would agree if anyone's
gonna pull this off first it's Tim
Dillon Shane Gillis and Bert Kreischer
competed in the 2023 busting with the
boys Beer Olympics last weekend and boy
did it look fun probably the top two
binge drinkers in comedy right now team
shirt krillis seemed like a shoe-in to
win this whole thing especially with
their matching Notre Dame polos on but
apparently the fellas ended up taking a
loss in the end I don't know why but
it's always pretty cool to see NFL
players and comedians hanging out and
getting drunk but there's plenty more of
in this week's episode of Something's
burning with Shane will and Taylor guest
spots from last week The Joe Rogan
Experience had on Ice Cube your mom's
house talked with Rachel Wolfson kill
Tony this week was the 10-year with Joe
Rogan and Tom Segura two Bears won cave
was Bert and Country Wayne stavis were
all talked with Ian finance and Jordan
Jensen Chrissy chaos had on Mateo Lane
homeless pimp was on hey babe bad
friends talked with Adam DeVine Mansion
secret podcast head on Nate Marshall and
Lemire Lee Graham Hancock was guest on
flagrant and Bobby Lee was on we might
be drunk could I just bring something
else I've never mentioned in front of
you and I want to make it uncomfortable
because I love you so much oh I love
these at my house I love it sure yeah
yeah I love you too man sure you've
never [__] me over I [__] you over
what time what did I do oh [__] so do
you know who this guy is yes yeah right
nice guys so what time before I met you
uh-huh you're younger and we're at the
Improv and I was supposed to go next and
you went into this guy because he was
the promoter of the show and you said to
him no I'm gonna go up before Bobby and
I remember getting one whoa who is this
guy bumping me like I've never heard of
this [__] jackass he's a legend in
Ella and then Jeffrey was like this guy
was like no he's allowed
I was like [__] that guy oh forever but
now we're friends and I didn't realize
yeah but now we're good I don't know
what it was I think I think what
happened was I had already gotten bumped
by like three people so you do remember
that night that makes I remember yeah
was Leno there that night yeah sorry I
got bumped by like three people and I
was like I'm [__] leaving if I'm not
I I I already have issues with LA right
and I'm sorry the one time La in La guy
showed me any [__] respect that hurt
you Bobby
[Laughter]
Mark and I get zero respect in L.A zero
this past weekend with the Yvonne talked
with Tom segora Josh Wolf was on the
Heartland Highway are you garbage out on
Dave Smith taste buds battled whipped
cream versus chocolate syrup Sam Tripoli
went on the Honeydew Annie Letterman was
on first date Joel McHale was guest on
Whiskey Ginger Tom Papa was on the
blocks podcast Bonnie McFarland was on
you know what dude and Bill Bellamy was
on tigerbelly as far as new stand-up
specials are either out right now we're
coming out soon Tom segor's brand new
hour Sledgehammer came out this morning
on Netflix this is Tom's fifth Netflix
special in the last nine years be sure
to keep an eye out for a post in our
community section coming soon asking
comedy fans to react to Sledgehammer if
you want your comment read in an
upcoming video Kevin Hart's new special
called reality check is coming out on
peacock July 6th which should be really
good as well some new specials out on
YouTube for you as well Matt rife's full
crowd work hour is up right now on his
page and not technically a special but
just Johnson had some new stand-up from
the comedy seller put out on his YouTube
channel right now let me know in the
comments what you think of this whole
YouTube Rumble Twitter situation and if
you'd ever want a joke world rumble or
Twitter account let me know that as well
be sure to keep an eye out for some new
videos coming out on this channel soon
including the funniest podcast moments
from July that might already be posted
or it's going to be out soon either way
that's gonna be a great video so if you
don't want to miss it be sure to hit
subscribe right now have a great Fourth
of July and thank you so much for
watching
and the world is wrld
[Music]